hi my name is Beau Biden Attorney
General of the state of Delaware here to
talk to you about something that's very
important to me and to my office senior
abuse for every one of these types of
crimes it's reported to our office five
go unreported but two million senior
Americans are affected every year
eighty percent eighty percent of these
crimes are committed by family members
against their so-called loved one we
need your help seniors need your help so
if you suspect that anyone is affected
by any of these crimes please contact
our elder abuse hotline
what's shaking people I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it is June the
5th 2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals subscribe if you have
not post game show as always at
reubenreport.locals.com and dare I say
I say it every now and again but dare I
say it today we have a tremendous
program for you it's one of our
thickests one of our densest and you
know putting on a good show like this is
uh it's like cooking you have to have
the right ingredients you have to have
the right equipment and tools and pans
you have to set the oven to the right
temperature and I feel people today that
we have all the right ingredients for a
nine nine but don't take my word for it
let's see uh we're going to be covering
a whole bunch if you did not see it
Chuck Todd of NBC news democrat activist
Chuck Todd who pretend pretended to be a
non-partisan journalist but was actually
a hack journalist he has stepped down
well either step down it's a little
unclear he's either stepped down or they
stepped him down from NBC News he'll be
stepping aside from Meet the Press and
uh that's sort of going to frame the
show today because he's a perfect
example of what the media has become
what the corporate press how has become
they have gotten almost everything wrong
and or backwards especially on this
gender front I don't know if you have
heard about all of this trans craziness
have you heard about it it's happening
people and don't forget this is only day
five of pride month and as I said on
Friday if your genitals are still
attached to you consider yourself lucky
so the question is how do we get out of
all of this well we gotta fight it we
gotta call it out we gotta create new
things we got to fix the culture and I
feel we can do it but before we get to
all that let's talk about
fastgrowingtrees.com you know what guys
you can breathe some life into your own
backyard with fastgrowingtreeds.com this
summer from shade to fresh fruit to
privacy and natural beauty let fast
growing trees.com help you plant your
dream garden with their expert advice
and fast reliable shipping
fastgrowingtrees.com plant experts
curate thousands of easy to grow plant
shrub and tree varieties for your unique
climate Meyer lemons to Evergreens and
everything in between no more waiting in
long lines and hauling heavy plants
around with fastgrowingtrees.com you
order online and your plants arrive at
your door in a couple days I love fast
growing trees when we moved in here we
threw up a couple well what do we have
right now we've got avocados we've got
mangoes we've got Tomatoes we've got all
kinds of stuff and you definitely should
check them out I can't recommend them
enough and with fast growing trees 30
day alive and Thrive guarantee you know
that everything will look great fresh
out of the box join Over 1.5 million
happy fast growing trees customers go to
or grow to
fastgrowingtrees.com Reuben right now to
get 15 off your first order 15 off at
fastgrowingtrees.com Reuben all right
let's get right into it Chuck Todd
ladles and jelly spoons has announced
his resignation from Meet the Press
so I leave feeling concerned about this
moment in history but reassured by the
standards we've set here we didn't
tolerate propagandus and this network
and program never will
but it doesn't mean sticking your head
in the sand either if you ignore reality
you'll miss the big story being a real
political journalist isn't about
building a brand
it's about reporting what's happening
and explaining why it's happening and
letting the public absorb the facts if
you do this job seeking popularity you
are doing this job incorrectly I take
the attacks from partisans as
compliments and I take the compliments
from partisans with a grain of salt
the goal of this and every Meet the
Press episode is to do all of the
following in one informative hour
make you mad make you think shake your
head in disapproval
and Nod your head in approval if you do
all of that in one hour of this show
we've done our job
oh Lord ending in style with an overly
pre-written statement that's pure
nonsense this is a guy and trust me
we're going to lay out our case with
video Don't You Worry uh who has either
lied or confused people or omitted
information or basically just debased
what journalism is uh pretty much
relentlessly for the last couple years
so we thought we'd go into some of his
Greatest Hits now by the way I want to
note that although they're saying he
resigned you just don't know and it's
largely Irrelevant in a certain extent
meaning people are tuning out of these
shows in droves but the mainstream media
the corporate press does still exist to
an extent a certain amount of people pay
attention to it to an extent and even
for all of the people like you guys that
maybe are tuning in more to say Megan
Kelly or Ben Shapiro or me or Crowder
whoever it might be we still have to get
some of our news from those corporate
media Outlets because that's often where
the taste makers the newsmakers the
president candidates Etc are going so
that's just a an odd place that we're in
at the moment the the dying dinosaur of
corporate press still has an inordinate
inordinate amount of power even though
everyone's views are elsewhere we get
more views on a daily basis than than
Meet the Press is getting on a Sunday
that's just a fact but okay fine so be
it here is uh one of Chuck Todd's would
we say this is a finer moment of Tuck
Chuck
I should have been calling him that the
whole time this is Chuck Todd doing
journalism
nearly 10 000 people died in the month
of June they were needless deaths please
get vaccinated if you know someone who's
not vaccinated find a way to convince
them to get vaccinated literally the
only people die are the unvaccinated and
for those of you spreading
misinformation shame on you
shame on you
people are needlessly dying because of
your misinformation
think about it I don't know how some of
you sleep at night who are doing this
for a living shame on you shame on you
Chuck Todd for lying about everything
relentlessly and it wasn't just
unvaccinated people who were getting
killed I don't know how you sleep lying
and carrying water for pharmaceutical
companies you're not a very good person
Chuck Todd you should be stepping down
in shame
good zoom good zoom very good gotter uh
here's more on some of the Great Moments
of Chuck Todd's uh tenure over at Meet
the Press you may remember this one uh
Ron Johnson senator from Wisconsin uh
when he smacked him down over the hunter
Biden laptop Fiasco or non-fiasco
depending on which way you look at it
Chuck is it a crime to be uh soliciting
and purchasing uh prostitution in
potentially European sex trafficking
operations is that a crime because Chuck
grass and I laid out about thirty
thousand dollars uh paid by Hunter Biden
to those types of of individuals over uh
December 2018 2019 about thirty thousand
dollars this is about the same time that
President Biden offered to pay about a
hundred thousand dollars of Hunter
Biden's bills I mean again that's that's
just some information I don't know
exactly all right it doesn't doesn't
really look on the it sounds sleazy as
you know I'll take care I'll take out
your word that you're ethically bothered
by Hunter Biden I'm curious though you
seem to have I do not uh
carrying water for the Democrats I mean
you see that you see what he was doing
right there Ron Johnson is excellent
he's really uh you know having sat down
with him you know you meet some of these
politicians and they're like a little
neither here nor there or sometimes
they're a little weird when looking at
you something like that this guy is like
a freaking laser he's like basically
dude dude he's paying off prostitutes
International prostitutes at the same
time that we know uh his dad Joe Biden
is lending him all this money could you
think there's something there maybe
Chuck Todd awful here's Chuck Todd
getting destroyed by Byron Donalds over
the IRS
but there's one more thing House
Republicans are asking for which is they
want fewer IRS agents they want fewer
attempts to try to properly uh get tax
receipts into the federal government's
coffers I have never understood the
resistance of extra IRS agents uh unless
you knowingly cheat on your taxes oh
that first of all that's that's
salacious and you know that most
Americans by far pay their taxes and
they do it honorably well House
Republicans and frankly Republican party
is concerned about is having IRS agents
go after middle-class families and small
business owners when you have that many
more agents it's not to go after the
rich it's to go after the middle again
so if you're if you're paying what
you're supposed to pay then you should
have nothing to fear you would make the
assumption that IRS audits are up that
they're they're putting out more liens
on the American people that's not true
that data is not guys there was a long
list of videos we could have chosen from
and we're going to show you at least one
more maybe two uh but that one to me
like this idea if you haven't done
anything wrong you have nothing to worry
about like what a freaking corporatist
sellout every single person every single
person watching this you would want less
power to the IRS right you would want
them to be looking into people a little
bit less you would want to keep a little
bit more of your money but that weird
this is why leftists are so weird
there's this there's this facade of
Tolerance and decency and right beneath
it is the worst type of authoritarian oh
did you decide well we'll find something
because they'll always find something
wrong right
here this one's from a couple weeks ago
we played this one for you uh he had
Vivek Rama Swami on uh and Chuck's a
little confused about how many genders
there are so vivec did a nice job using
trademark science
how do you know it's that again how do
you know are you confident that you know
that gender uh is uh as binary as you're
describing it are you confident that it
isn't a spectrum I am you know this as a
scientist well there's there's two X
chromosomes if you're a woman an X and A
Y that means
there's a lot of scientific research out
there that says gender is a spectrum
Chuck I respectfully disagree gender
dysphoria for most of our history all
the way through the DSM-5 has been
characterized as a mental health
disorder and I don't think it's
compassionate to affirm that I think
that's cruelty when a kid is crying out
for help what they're asking for is
you've got to ask the question of what
else is going wrong at home what else is
going wrong at school let's be
compassionate and get to the heart of
that rather than playing this game as
though we're actually changing our
medical understanding for the last time
yeah that's good work by bevec and uh
I'm in a little Twitter spot with vivec
at the moment which we're going to get
to in a moment but as you know I like
giving the devil is due and when you do
good work and you confront these guys
and call them out on their nonsense
Chuck Todd knows there's a man and
there's a woman and then if you want to
be a man who dresses like a woman and
acts like a woman and names uh yourself
a female name as an adult blah blah blah
blah blah almost everybody is on board
you live in your life as you see fit but
that was a nice job of just clean clear
explanation by vivec I have to say on a
personal note what I'm about to do is
now a little disappointing because I I
kind of like vivec as you know I've
interviewed Vivek a couple times we've
we've had dinner we uh I think he's a
decent dude and it's a I think he's a
good addition to the Republican field uh
but I think he's acting in bad faith on
a couple things so we're going to shift
this a little bit a little bit away from
Chuck Todd for the moment over the
weekend vivec uh tweeted this out
Ron DeSantis signed a hate speech Bill
earlier this year at his donor's request
I respectfully disagree the right answer
to bad speech isn't less speech it's
more speech that's the American way then
he got community noted on that on
Twitter now Community notes that's their
fact checking it's their crowd-sourced
fact-checking thing Ron DeSantis did not
sign a hate speech bill as you guys know
because you're a bright audience uh the
Supreme Court has ruled that there is no
such thing as hate speech right you're
allowed to say mean things to people
we'll get into the details of what Ron
desantis's Bill uh was all about in just
a second it was far more of a property
Rights bill and a religious liberty Bill
than anything else but vivec knew that
he was lying there and also that he said
at the donor's request right like he
completely made that up he has no
evidence that someone gave Ron DeSantis
money and then Ron DeSantis signed a
hate speech law I assure you there is
nothing that you can't say in Florida uh
that you somehow can say in Ohio where
he's from from or any of the other
states anyway he got community noted on
it so they put a fact check on his tweet
then vivec tweeted this this is an
unbelievable move by Twitter to Shield
Ron DeSantis from legitimate criticisms
of his policies let's just hope it's
another innocent mistake like they made
yesterday with their controversial
censorship of the daily wire but it
doesn't smell awesome Ron DeSantis
enacted a law criminalizing the
distribution of kinds of certain kinds
of literature on private property that's
a hate speech law and I said so now
that's an absolute lie I'll get to that
in a second next DeSantis online trolls
and larger DeSantis influencers like
Ruben report complained to community
notes to throttle my tweet that's also a
lie I'll explain that complaining that
it wasn't technically a hate speech law
I disagree with them because it's
absolutely a hate speech law in its
effect notwithstanding the Law's title
good semantics but then the censorship
czars at Twitter which notably launched
the DeSantis campaign and pumped it up
with owner Elon musk and DeSantis Mega
donor David Sachs abided the request of
these DeSantis supporters by throttling
my tweet that criticized the DeSantis
law in summary self-professed Free
Speech Advocates who support DeSantis
are using a so-called Free Speech
platform to suppress legitimate debate
about speech restraining to law to
protect a politician they favor that's
corporate interference in an election
but not in the way you'd expect I was
censored last week on LinkedIn for
posting videos arguing against the
climate agenda and Biden's relationship
with China that was bad but this is
worse The Establishment now includes
those who like to pose as
anti-establishment which is more
dangerous because some people actually
believe their charade it's also also
interesting to note that this comes a
few days after I questioned Elon Musk
for his posture towards China it will be
interesting to see if there's any quiet
Shadow Banning of my tweets going
forward lastly the Twitter Community
notes that they have qualified that they
have to qualify with per se suggests
they shouldn't have been involved in the
matter at all okay
there's a lot there in that rambling uh
slightly conspiratorial diatribe he's
somehow implying that Elon Musk and uh
David Saxon potentially I are all
working to throttle his tweets through
Twitter that's complete nonsense
Community notes elon's not running
Community notes it's their crowd-funded
fact check system that's how it works
okay so everyone anyone can be fact
checked right that's absolutely how it
works and that's far better than what
was happening before when either
government interlockers that were
working at Twitter or Bad actors at
Twitter Etc were just silencing people
and Shadow Banning them everything else
this is very transparent if you lie
about something they put a warning on
your Tweet with an explanation of it and
a link so people can find out more
information he also said that there are
certain types of literature that cannot
be distributed in Florida it is a
hundred percent live Avec you know it's
a lie I'm going to read exactly what
what is in the bill in the moment but
there is nothing about specific
literature you can distribute
anti-semitic literature or or anti-gay
literature or anything else you can't do
it on someone else's private property
it's a it's about property rights so he
knows he's lying about that and then
there's just sort of this Grand
conspiracy that he's going to be
throttled because of this and everything
else anyway the the uh representative
the congressman from Florida whose bill
it was that DeSantis ultimately signed
uh his name's Randy fine he responded to
vivec and uh after Vivek said this was a
hate speech law and he wrote except it
isn't it was my bill if you believe
someone should be able to come onto your
property without your consent and deface
it and consider that speech you're an
idiot happy to school you
all right this is what politics does to
everybody okay it is what it is but the
point is this is about property right so
here's one of these things where it's
like Vivek says something the other
people say something that no one knows
what the truth is so I'm going to
actually read to you what is in the bill
now also keep in mind if it was a hate
speech law meaning if if DeSantis had
signed something that said you can't say
these certain things
it would 100 be against the Constitution
I would 100 be against it and by the way
it would be hung up in the courts right
now right because somebody would have
sued about it and it would be on its way
to the Supreme Court where the Supreme
Court very easily would be able to give
it a unanimous decision and be like Oh
in Florida you can't say that let's
strike that law down but hence none of
that's happening anyway from the Florida
gov website uh HB 269 builds upon
Governor DeSantis record of safeguarding
the free exercise of religion in Florida
by it I'm going to redo the bullet
points and you tell me what you can't
say in Florida
prohibiting a person from intentionally
dumping litter onto a private property
for the purpose of intimidating or
threatening the owner resident or
invitee of such property prohibiting a
person from willfully and maliciously
harassing threatening or intimidating
another person based on that person's
wearing or displaying of any Indica
related to any religious or ethnic
Heritage Indica is that what they say in
is it Indica like the weed I have the
word what what does indicia what does
that mean in Context of this can you
Google that just out of sheer curiosity
next up creating a new prohibition
against displaying or projecting using
any medium an image onto a building
structure or other property without the
written consent of the owner of the
building structure or property
creating a new trespass offense if a
person who is not authorized licensed or
invited willfully enters the campus of a
state college or university for the
purpose of threatening or intimidating
another person and is warned by the
institution to depart and refuses to do
so and prohibiting a person from
willfully and maliciously interrupting
or disturbing any assembly met for the
purpose of acknowledging the death of an
individual so just to be clear here guys
every single thing there there's the vet
completely lied when he said this is
about specific types of literature as
you can see there's nothing about
specific types of literature you cannot
targetedly harass people at their homes
or their places of worship or anything
else and it tightens up the penalties
around that that's all it does I'm
fairly certain you know me well enough
that there if there was any infringement
on someone's speech here that that
certainly would be something that I was
against against I think we're getting
the definition of indisha is it indicia
is that how you would pronounce it
signs indications or distinguished
distinguishing marks I did not know that
and I read the thing twice today God
damn anyway I happen to by
total coincidence because we were doing
this trip I happen to be in Israel the
day that Ron DeSantis signed this bill
listen to the specific clear and clean
way he explains what this is while
protecting the First Amendment and
people's right to say offensive things
you know things that some people call
hate speech
you in the United States you have uh
constitutionally protected right to say
whatever you want no matter how
distasteful it is no matter how hateful
it is and um and that's just that's just
the way it is but you don't have a right
uh to threaten people you don't have a
right to harass people uh you don't have
a right to intimidate somebody
particularly on the basis of somebody's
religious affiliation or whether they
may be wearing a keepa that is different
than just expressing your opinion and so
we are looked I think the legislature
looked okay what can we do in Florida uh
to enhance the ability uh to hold people
accountable when they're not just giving
an opinion however distasteful it is but
when that really crosses the line into
threatening conduct and and that's what
the legislature has done this is going
to provide more tools to be able to
combat anti-semitic activity including
things like you know if you have a
synagogue dog and someone shines a
swastika like image on that you know
they have a right to have to do the
image for themselves but putting it on
someone else's property that they're
defining that this bill is a trespass
and you could be held accountable for
infringing on somebody else's property
rights and so what they're doing is
really saying okay obviously we're we're
gonna uphold the First Amendment and
there's just no way around that and
honestly uh you're much better off just
having everything be protected than try
to pick and choose but when you have
this type of conduct what can you do so
now there's going to be more tools to be
able to do that
I have to say in case you don't know it
I am so freaking proud that that guy is
my governor and that he is running for
president United States do you notice
how many times he qualified it defending
the First Amendment defending people's
rights to say mean and bad things and
distasteful things and making the clear
distinction between that and then
targeted harassment right so that means
you can't be across the street as he
said you can't be across the street from
a temple and be blasting a swastika on
the side of the temple that's an
infringement on their property rights
because that's what this is about you
couldn't walk into a mosque and hand out
flyers with the picture of Muhammad on
it right that would be a property issue
because it's their property the mosque
right
um that's what this is all about it's
not that you can't say mean things to
people and again vivec 100
lied when he said there are certain
types of Flyers that you can't put out
there or whatever else so anyway it's
not fun having to like fight with these
people to a certain extent but I I do
think it's important that we would call
out the nonsense when we do so I I this
morning I tweeted this one I responded
to vivec I said uh good morning Vivek
there is no hate speech law here in
Florida and to prove it how about you
tweet something verbatim which I can't
say here in Florida that you can say in
the rest of the country I'll take my dog
for a walk and say it and we can see
what happens uh well uh to follow up on
that I did take Clyde for about an
hour-long walk and uh no vivec did not
get back to us on what it is that we
can't say here in Florida but we did
have an incident with Clyde take a look
it continues out here
lots of stuff happening we're chasing a
peacock we're chasing a peacock we're
chasing a peacock chasing a peacock okay
quite a bit flip-flops slow it down I
gotta tell you man when a dog is pulling
you chasing a peacock and you're wearing
sliders I said flip-flops but
technically they were the sliders uh
it's tough it's tough so that's what
happened to me today okay we're just
doing the best we can over here anyway I
welcome vivec to uh retract what he said
you know you lied about the bill you're
spreading misinformation you're you're
portraying yourself as I'm the Bold
truth teller right so you lied about the
fact that somehow a donor forced the
scientist to do this you lied about the
fact that uh it has anything to do with
hate speech or stopping anyone from
saying anything you know you lied you
got called out on it by thousands of
other people besides me so just like
retracted unless spivec are you working
with Trump is it possible you're working
with Trump that's what a lot of people
are saying right now and are you doing
Trump's dirty work because it's kind of
funny you're never going after Trump and
we're to believe that Trump's 30 points
ahead so generally you'd be going after
the big fish right you'd generally be
going after that guy taking that out but
it's odd because seemingly nobody's
going after Trump these days well the
prosecutor in New York is but right the
entire machine is always focused on
DeSantis very odd number two so Vivek I
I would challenge you you must have some
disagreements with Donald Trump unless
you've cut some sort of deal with him
could that could that be Vivek what's
going on
anywho uh speaking of disinformation and
uh copying the the tactics of mainstream
media figures like Chuck Todd which
unfortunately Vivek just did let's dive
back into the mainstream media uh here
is uh Chuck Todd reflecting on the
mainstream media of today
the White House says President Biden is
fine tonight hours after he tripped and
fell during a graduation ceremony at the
Air Force Academy the president is fine
he's fine as the president simply
tripped Falls are really common this is
not some sort of uh ominous Talisman
about his medical condition everything
seems to be totally fine uh just a
misplaced sandbag we will show you in
the corner of a screen see there's a
sandbag and you know it's the advanced
team or whoever's fault that they put a
sandbag in front of him his staff should
uh you know make sure there aren't
obstacles like sandbags in his way
Twitter and the writer going crazy it's
currently dominating Fox News prime time
tonight new questions about President
Trump's Health after this walk down a
ramp at West Point's Graduation Ceremony
this weekend his halting journey down a
ramp new questions about his health
where he cautiously descended a ramp the
nation in crisis and the president
tweeting about his walk down a ramp is
where we start today the President also
raised some questions during his West
Point speech after taking a moment to to
sip some water it was lacking the
strength to raise the water glass there
he was the video's up now struggling he
takes one step with his left foot and
then the right foot comes and meets the
left foot well it's more than uh just
the way he walked Aaron he doesn't look
right this is not the first time the
president has had difficulty walking
down ramps his speech has become very
very slow as if he's struggling to read
from the teleprompter stumbled for
stumble Donald Trump seems to be right
in line with Joe Biden or in many ways
even worse all right first off we have
to issue an on-the-fly correction
because we're willing to do that here at
the Reuben report that was obviously not
a video of Chuck decide what I was
trying to say I got a little crossed up
on the property there I didn't realize
what we were throwing to it's the
tactics of Chuck Todd how the media
covers one thing one way and doesn't
cover another thing or covers it in a
complete opposite direction that
obviously leads you to this Biden and
Trump video right when Biden Falls when
Biden slurs when Biden doesn't know
where he is when Biden has cue cards
they run cover for it or they ignore it
all together when Donald Trump walked
slowly down a ramp because the ramp was
wet or when he drank a glass of water
with two hands they were literally
calling for the 25th Amendment so that
is consistently what happens here but
anyway Biden did have that big fall on
Thursday and fortunately he is okay
right I do not want the president of the
United States to be incapacitated and I
certainly don't want it when you know
who the number two is we found this very
factual video I'm sure this one is very
factual and not manipulated in any way
by the meme makers on the internet uh
Joe Biden explaining exactly what
happened to him the other day
my fellow Americans these Maga
extremists are now using sandbags to
attack us and these are are not regular
sandbags these are racist sandbags
Donald Trump is now using ultramaga
extremist sandbags against us so I'm
directing the FBI to arrest him before
the 2024 election thank you
let me get a fact check on that one
anyway uh you see the point of all of
this they run cover for Dems you know it
and then they intentionally inflate or
lie about Republicans constantly uh
here's a really wild portion of an
interview this weekend from the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC uh Jen saki now jensaki who
obviously is a Democrat activist she
worked for the Biden Administration she
was press secretary and then what
happens when you are a horrible horrible
press secretary who lies about
everything you then get a job on MSNBC
right after to continue your line Shia
James Comey on and uh here is James
Comey basically saying the quiet part
out loud you would think that you know
the directors of our agencies say the
CIA the FBI things of this nature would
try to remain apolitical because you'd
want these agencies to be thought of as
apolitical they just abide by the law
they don't care if it's a Republican or
a Democrat in office but listen to James
Comey on what he wants to happen in
2024. you're a republican most of your
life but voted for and you may can still
consider yourself one but voted for
Biden in 2020 do you intend to vote for
him again or is there anyone on the
Republican side you might consider if
it's not Trump
it has to be Joe Biden
and and I'm glad he's willing to serve
it has to be somebody committed to the
rule of law committed to the values of
this country and I'm not talking about
policy people can disagree about policy
there are things above those
disagreements that all of us should
think about the same way the president
must be someone who abides the law in
our Constitution and there's no one else
but Joe Biden wow there is so much there
I can't even believe they let that video
get out because it's such a who's behind
the curtain moment first off she says
you're still a republican that he's
going like this so okay that's that's
just kind of interesting but secondly to
say that there is no one besides Joe
Biden that will abide by the law dude
you're showing your cards way too much
like sometimes you accidentally show the
cards a little bit look oh look at that
no this time you're just showing us the
hopeful thing right there you're telling
me Nikki Haley would not abide by the
law like put aside DeSantis I get it to
say it this is your Boogeyman Trump is
your Boogeyman uh Nikki Haley wouldn't
abide by the law Tim Scott would not
abide by the law Chris Christie or Mike
Pence would not abide by law there is
literally no Republican who would abide
by the law and the only Democrat who
must do it and must do it again must be
the verily very elderly man who's
confused and constantly falling and then
I don't know if you saw it but over the
weekend he also then banged his head
into the helicopter as he was getting
out like it just doesn't end with this
guy it's just propaganda and you really
have to understand like once they have
politicized these institutions like the
FBI that he was in charge of like the
CIA Etc it's like then we have a real
problem now we know we have this problem
right because we know that the lies were
being laundered of Russia collusion and
all that through the FBI this entire
time and the CIA and all of the stuff
but he's coming out and saying it I mean
I kind of thank him for it because
hopefully that will wake up some other
people but
on the media side of this let's connect
that further to what's going on with the
media the media is always pushing a
leftist agenda right so they bring on
the former FBI guy to say that you have
to vote for Biden if you want to defend
the rule of law oh and that the idea
that Biden is the one that will defend
the rule of law really because when
Biden was forcing companies to force
people to have medical procedures that
they didn't want shots and injections
they didn't want was that the rule of
law I don't think so uh anyway here is
speaking of the mainstream media they
have been really pushing this person
lately this is Montana state
representative Zoe Zephyr uh who
apparently is trans so what you're going
to see in a moment is it's a biological
man who is living life as a woman and as
an adult that's just fine and listen to
the propaganda that he or she is now
pushing on the mainstream media and the
way that they swallow it whole
but what we see in moments like this is
that the people who support anti-lgbtq
bills they're not content with a single
piece of policy they want to see us
removed from All Stars they want to see
us removed from public life and to me
that's why it's so important in this
moment that we fight
okay there are no anti-lgbt laws there
are no laws that are coming for gay
people or Lesbos or bisexuals there are
some laws out there right now to protect
children from having their genitals
mutilated
I'm pretty sure that if Christians were
mutilating the genitals of children
chopping off their wangs that the LGBT
movement would be very against it but
you see how these people do how they
operate they have very little to do with
reality and then no one on that set
that's CNN so they could turn to him or
her and say can you tell me what what
rights they are taking away from gay
people are gay people not allowed to get
married are gay people not allowed to
work are lesbians not allowed to do
whatever it is lesbians are doing
but there is no such thing so they just
this is one of the times where they lie
they lie by promoting someone that
promotes a lie and then they also Lie by
omitting any honest critique of what
that person is saying
uh but what's happening right now it
seems to me is something interesting
we're getting to a moment now where it's
gone so absolutely crazy on the trans
side of things and the denial of reality
that good people are not only waking up
and we know this this has been happening
for a while right this has been
happening at uh local school boards with
parents getting involved this has been
happening with with grass roots uh
people deciding hey I'm not going to
fund things that are going against the
way reality it's not even it's not even
my lifestyle it's reality but light
Target etc etc check out this video this
is from the Dr Phil show it's a fifth
grade teacher so he's just a fifth grade
teacher this guy trying to explain basic
biology to several trans activists and
watch how it goes
transgender boys who might not have
their own money to go buy tampons if
they're provided free in the bathroom
it's it's a huge plus men do not
menstruate only women menstrate now you
can call yourself whatever you want
right but trans men do menstrual
non-binary people menstrating is not
exclusive yes it is women no it's not
yes it is
if your chromosomes are XX and you're
young you menstruate if you're XY you
don't correct but what about trans men
and non-violence we're not shooting a
whole group they're women dressed as men
you are not a man you pretend to be a
man and that's okay that's perfectly
fine live your life tell me what a man
is well what's a man to you you define a
man for me you have chromosomes that are
X and Y that's what a man is so why are
we just looking at the the the the
science of this as an assignment when
when we've learned sex and gender
identity a two very the completely
different things they are completely
different completely different words
this is what you're born with the sexual
reproductive organs you have
identify with
accept that distinction you have to
argue for it you're just giving a
conclusion you're you're just making it
up people the people who hate the truth
people who hate the truth are because
they see they see the truth is hateful
if you want to identify in any way you
can you're free to do so but that does
not mean that the rest of us have to
join that illusion I have to say that's
the third time I've watched that video
today and that teacher right can we can
we find him I'd love to have him on
because what a what a calm decent
explainer of the truth and you know it's
funny you know I always say this thing
about how when you're telling the truth
you don't have to be screaming and you
can sort of tell it in people's body
languages because you can just
communicate it honestly without being
hysterical and everything even the way
he's kind of sitting there like well you
guys have come to the conclusion it's
not reality but you've come to that
conclusion not based on solid arguments
or science I love how she's suddenly for
science
oh yeah right all right it's okay fine
um we got to get that guy on the show I
think he'd be and he's just a fifth
grade teacher who's putting his butt on
the line to do that because I have no
doubt that he's getting a ton of of hate
on that but good for Dr Phil to even
have that be willing to have that
conversation and I just want to say one
other thing on this before we move on to
the next clip if you're a dude and your
vagina is bleeding you've got a problem
okay
clip that and send it around the
internet uh anyway we saw this one
online uh just to break it up today how
about a satirical short on pronouns and
what straight white guys can do to be
cool are you feeling left out of the
oppression Olympics introducing faith
and pronouns they them pronouns are the
number one way for generic white people
to enter a perceived marginalized
community so what do I have to do
differently that's the best part
absolutely nothing you don't have to
dress differently act differently or
even date differently just put they them
in your bio and bang you'll get more
attention instantly I had no way to
signal to people that I was part of the
tribe because I can't take a black
square with me everywhere I go but now
with my new pronouns everybody knows I'm
part of the tribe looking for something
else we've got all your pronoun needs
we've got hymns hers verse zems we even
got a couple thongs in the back mix and
match with he they or our best seller
shivay hurry they're going fast get him
before this sexuality fad dies out and
it's no longer cool to do this so what
are you waiting for stop on in today
them
[Music]
oh look the point of that is guys it's
it's good that people are starting to
make fun of this right because you don't
just beat these ideas by truth right you
don't beat these ideas like oh men have
penises women have vaginas like that
doesn't work with these people right so
you can beat them hopefully with some
satire getting young people to be like
okay there is reality and when you say
something about it that is true in a
funny way it often will like get a
couple neurons to fire that may not when
you're just like no reality is this and
read it in a textbook and hear science
and blah blah blah but what's what's the
point of all this the point of all is as
these radical activists Rampage through
the schools these are the people that
are teaching your children and
everything else well then this stuff
bubbles up into uh public policy uh
check this out what's going on in New
Mexico right now talk about a place
going in the wrong direction New Mexico
New Mexico Governor Michelle Lawson
Grisham signs law that will permit
minors to access sex change care and
abortions without parental knowledge or
consent
that strikes me as so deeply
I mean criminal I would say and deeply
unethical and everything else like you
are going to without parents consent
that means a 15 year old is going to
show up at a gender Clinic who may just
be confused about their sexuality or
whatever else is going on in their life
and that without parental consent you
were going to start drugging them and
operating on them and you are going to
give them genitals that do not work and
that will be what's happening in New
Mexico so when we talk about the states
going their separate directions and that
there are going to be red states that
are functioning and decent and within
the bounds of reality and everything
else Florida Texas
Etc
then there are going to be blue States
New York Cali that are going to be doing
things like this New Mexico and they
will take your children away from you
and operate them and mutilate them and
you're going to put up for it get the
hell out of New Mexico if you are there
right now with the young kid before they
do something awful to your children but
it continues all of this lunacy
continues and guess what sometimes it
actually does leak into the places that
are thought of the as the same places
Dallas Texas check this one out from the
Dallas Express News exclusive an
internal city of Dallas gender
transition toolkit requires all public
employees to use a transitioning
person's preferred pronouns regardless
of personal beliefs that is absolutely
incredible and by the way that actually
is an infringement on your first
amendment rights that the government is
saying to you you can
at work cannot call this person whatever
you want now
it goes without saying if someone's
being respectful of you you should be
respectful of them this has nothing to
do with the government this is just
basic matters and it's it's like a
social construct that we all kind of a
social contract actually I should say
that we all kind of sign on to it's like
if you think about this in your own life
just in your own life if you were at
work and there was an adult
who happened to be uh trans or just
dressing up as a different thing
and they're respectful and they're
decent and they're not forcing you to
deny reality or forcing you to change
your views on everything but you know
you once knew them as Robert and now
they're Roberta and they got a bow in
their hair and lipstick and the whole
thing but Robert is very nice and
Roberta does a good job and everything
else then I think the social contract we
have As Americans is to is to you don't
have to accept it it doesn't have to be
something that changes your views on
anything but you can treat that person
with respect and by the way that respect
is a two-way street but when the
government is now saying You must use
the gender pronouns that that person
wants I'd like vivec to chime in on this
one right so it bleeds into all of our
governmental institutions all of our
cultural institutions and everything
else uh here's a tweet from Ashley
Sinclair because as you know it is pride
month so John fetterman showed up to I
think that's Philly Pride if I'm not
mistaken fetterman dressed up more for a
pride parade than for a senate
conference he looks thrilled doesn't he
he always looks thrilled that guy to be
in his gay Cape with his wife and her
gay outfit and of course that's
contrasting what he wears normally when
he's uh in Congress which in the house
over there a hoodie and shorts and
sneakers I mean this Porsche muck he
doesn't know where he is what are they
doing to this guy and also like what
what are you saying by putting that cape
on again there are no bills coming after
gay people there are by the way there's
also no such thing as gay rights there's
no such thing as lesbian rights there's
no such thing as black rights there are
individual rights okay and if there were
laws that were targeting these people
based on those specific things then we
would have a problem we don't have those
things again it's all about kids but
here's Corin Jean-Pierre or cringe
Jean-Pierre as I like to say uh
completely lying and confusing people
about what's happening
reality is this year has been really
scary for our community people are being
treated frightened intimidated
and targeted for who they are and who
they love this year alone more than 600
anti-lgbtqi bills have been filed in
state houses across the country and a
significant portion of those bills
Target transgender youth as President
Biden says these young people are some
of the bravest people he knows but no
one should have to be brave to be
themselves now you have to remember this
is what they do with everything 600
bills she doesn't tell you what's any in
any of those bills at the end there she
kind of says oh well there's a couple
about transgender youth well again yes
we are agreed on that that that let's
say our side in this case is trying to
protect children from being mutilated so
we might just have a different opinion
on what you would do with that right
again and it's so interesting because
everybody whether it's that teacher
whether it's me whether it's virtually
anyone in this space even DeSantis who's
done more at a governmental level than
anybody else everyone always goes out of
their way with these qualifying things
that live your life as you see fit if
you're an adult and that's really the
problem with the radicals there we are
giving you guys virtually everything you
want no one's saying put trans people in
jail you know what I mean no one's it's
a protection of children but everyone's
saying live however the freak you want
to live but stop denying our stop
denying real reality and stop pushing it
on children it's as simple as that so
she doesn't go into I'd like her to list
them hey cringe cringe whatever the hell
your name is if you're watching today
how about you tomorrow list those bills
tell us what those bills are and what
rights they're coming for
crickets crickets crickets but if you
want to see how this all really works as
you know it's the media it's Tech it's
government and then it creates this
manufactured culture that no one really
believes is good or just or right except
the crazy radicals and the people that
are somehow pulling the strings check
this out this is from us I've never
heard of this comedian it doesn't even
matter what his or her name is but this
is a dude in a dress who got a Comedy
Central special uh doing stand-up or I
guess this is stand up uh really again
saying the quiet part out loud what they
are trying to do related to your ability
to say what is true this is supposedly
comedy but really listen to what he's
saying dude and address enjoy
this is the best time in the world to be
queer I'm so excited being queer is the
best thing that ever happened to me and
I walk around with like power I'm
walking like yeah
that's right because
everyone knows nowadays you can't say
anything
remotely sideways about queers if you if
you even slightly inconvenience a queer
person on TV 100 male ballet dancers
will show up outside your job and
probably until you come downstairs and
apologize
all right to be clear people that's Bob
the drag queen so Bob is not trans we do
have to make that distinction Bob is
just a dude Bob does acknowledge that
he's a dude I assume Bob is a gay guy
just dressing in a dress and telling
jokes but what underlies that joke right
and we played that clip the other day of
Elon talking about comedy and how comedy
really what you want to be doing is
saying something true and then you add a
Twist to it so that it can it can sort
of give you a revealed truth people then
laugh we can all sort of share that
together and we can maybe think about
things in a little bit of a different
way to Loosely quote Oscar Wilde if you
want to tell people the truth you better
be funny or they'll kill you but what
he's telling you there what Bob the drag
queen is telling you there is how
excited he is that if you say anything
that goes against the narrative that
he's for the let's say lgbtqi plus two
spirit whatever it is narrative that
they will take you out and they're very
happy that they have this new power
and it's just absolutely insane you know
what's funny I I I happen to
occasionally mention uh my sexuality on
the show because and really only within
the context of what's going on in
society right it's the least interesting
thing about me I don't really think
about it that often I get that it's a
little out there for some people and
some people have their own religious
views and everything else but I get a
ton of hate online people people calling
me all sorts of awful crap all the time
it's people on the far right and the far
left all the time I don't sit here and
about it nor go out of my way to
silence those people if it's on Twitter
maybe I'll block them or whatever it is
um but but the fact that he's feeling
empowered they're feeling empowered by
the fact that they can silence you uh
this is a real problem and I want to
show you a little bit more from that
Elon Musk interview with the Babylon B
guys a couple days ago because I think
he really nailed it here
if you've got people on the fringes on
both sides upset then you're doing
something right right yeah but when it
comes to lgbtq and Q and on right
simultaneously upset
um I was thinking that's why I think you
know things go full circle
lgbtq and on
[Laughter]
you could probably get me in trouble if
you like well probably will
you were saying
I just love that because I'm telling you
this guy is just telling you what he
thinks in real time lgbtq Anon that'll
probably get me in trouble like that's
the thing what we want to stop right now
are the crazies on both sides and and
the reason that I focus more on the
crazies of the left is it's the crazies
of the left that are fueling The Crazies
of the right there is nobody like
generally speaking on the right who is
like a you know like a true racist and
that they want people to have different
laws or a true homophobe and that they
want to jail gaze or whatever anything
is what they but the radicals on the
left have gone so crazy and because it's
pushed through mainstream and everything
else you're starting to empower the
radicals on the right and that is a
problem that really is a problem so
let's bring this thing full circle the
the truth guys that you know it that
fake mainstream media is doing
everything they can uh to go against
agendas that that are what the ones that
they want to push right this is what
they are constantly doing so here is the
fake news uh the NPC we call it the
non-playable character fake news
reporting on what happened with Twitter
over the last couple days so as you may
know I think we covered it briefly uh on
was it on Thursday night uh what is a
woman which is a movie a documentary by
Matt Walsh at the daily wire and all he
does in this documentary I highly
recommend you watch it it is not
transphobic or anything else he
basically is just sitting down with
activists and into intellectuals and a
bunch of people who refuse to say what a
woman is over and over and over and over
anyway the daily wire put that video on
Twitter Twitter then marked it with
something the internal system of Twitter
marked it that it wasn't Advertiser safe
uh I didn't comment on it in the morning
because I knew it was going to be worked
out like I just knew something was going
on here uh and then of course over a
couple hours uh Elon took care of it it
was no longer marked that then the head
of trust and safety there's been a new
head of trust and safety uh after Elon
took over that person then stepped down
because she wasn't happy that Elon did
the right thing and did not suppress the
video and now the video has over 100
million views on Twitter I mean it's a
it's a great story about actually free
speech working and people doing the
right thing and everything else and then
this woman quitting because apparently
she doesn't know what a woman is anyway
here is CNN reporting on Elon Musk
airing what is a woman
meantime Twitter's head of trust and
safety telling Reuters that she has
resigned from the social media company
Ella Irwin who was in charge of content
moderation stepped down the same day
that Twitter blocked and then unblocked
access to an anti-trans documentary
billionaire Elon Musk has faced
criticism for lacks protections against
potentially harmful content since he
took over back in October
no God the way they frame everything
again remember what I kept telling you
when Elon took over suddenly there were
all these articles about Elon Musk not
doing enough about child porn meanwhile
Elon Musk was actually going after child
born on Twitter and all of the people
who were writing those stories about how
Elon Musk isn't doing anything about
child porn on Twitter you could go back
and none of them were writing stories
about child porn on Twitter before Elon
muskatic because if they don't like Elon
Musk because Elon musk's Elon Musk likes
the Free Speech also again it's not an
anti-trans documentary asking someone
what is a woman like hello what's
reality that is not anti-trans unless
you think trans is counter to reality
starting to I think we're starting to
pick up on something so this is the
solution to defeat them guys you don't
defeat them by silencing them the way
they want to silence us right you don't
do what drag queen Bob
who will probably be the VP choice for
president once Kamala takes over for uh
Joe you don't do what ju what drag queen
Bob is so psyched to do which is make
sure that a mob is ready to take out
your opponents what you do is first you
fight for the right principles of free
speech right that's what you do first
you create your own entertainment so you
create better comedy that's why we
showed you a couple comedy things here
which are far funnier than Bob the drag
queen you start changing the actual
culture and then check this out so after
all of the brouhaha related to all of
this and that Elon Musk wasn't going to
show the video and then he did show the
video you know what his pin tweet on
Twitter is right now and the pin tweet
means it's at the top of your feed every
parent should watch this and look at the
numbers on that thing those are just the
numbers on his tweet alone uh 280 000
likes the video itself right now uh they
as of like right before we started the
show has about a hundred and seventy
million views so they butterfly affected
the hell out of this thing right and
maybe that's what Elon wanted maybe Elon
wanted there to be a little controversy
around it so that his own head of trust
and safety would die on The Sword which
this woman did and I wish her the best
of luck in in getting a new job where
she'll be able to censor and she'll
probably work at a company with a bunch
of lefties that deny reality and
everything else so guys it ain't that
complex be brave tell the truth build
your own systems make better content
that's how you do it that's how you beat
Chuck Cod I'm Dave Rubin this has been
the Reuben report oh it's me Monday I
put this one up this I really like this
one I saw it over the weekend this is
what I put up over at
reubenreport.locals.com gray Pride we're
old we're tired and get off our lawn
that's what I'm celebrating this month
this month and every month gray Pride
all right we've got a quick cold close
for you and we'll see everybody else are
you going to dig this one it's very
Florida focused and we'll see everybody
at reubenreport.locals.com in just a sec
all right ciao
when you see an alligator coming down
the street towards you it's only natural
to either drop your jaw or Panic that
he'll drop his
yeah
but alligator expert Joe Henney says his
alligator poses no threat I've never met
an alligator that will not bite you you
fool around the head like this they're
in sneakers to grab you he does not do
it you can reach in or rub his tongue he
refuses to close his mouth we don't know
why yeah there you go Wally was found in
a pond at Disney World he had to go and
since in Florida it's illegal to
relocate alligators to another spot in
the wild Joe agreed to take him in today
Wally lives on Cheetos and chicken legs
in Joe's house near Hershey Pennsylvania
without a cage good boy a few years ago
after Joe lost some people close to him
he says he fell into a deep depression
and about that same time he says Wally
began behaving differently more
affectionate almost like he sensed his
depression
[Music]